log onto your computer open your browser
and pop open a twitch tab what do you
see
maybe it's simple performing unspeakable
acts on stream let's [ __ ] go boys or
xqc directing his daily influx of rage
at the most trivial thing imaginable bad
yes maybe you're in the midst of
discovering that there is such a thing
as farm simulator eSports you don't dare
showing off here can they actually do
this careful come on make it stick this
would be impressive that's the count no
like so happy I could oh this is intro
how they do it nice just taking a stick
right out to the top it could be that
you're watching someone freak out or you
know sell out my success did not come
overnight now I wanted to five areas and
change what it means to be a pro gamer
and hey maybe you're just in it for the
fanservice it's slightly better just
don't like it though or somebody who
probably shouldn't be streaming at all
I'm sorry to your grandma died maybe
you're witnessing someone make history
it could hardly have been more difficult
they weren't the favorites they were the
underdogs they were a heavy under the
but a pitiful North America skip through
those one day my job or watching as they
dish out stomps in their sweatpants
whether you're in the mood for laughter
tears so Lesley well you are you marry
me or something in between twitch has
got you covered it's basically the
gaming equivalent of public transit the
one thing that brings people together
from all walks of life the medium
through which gamers approach and
understand themselves each other and the
world around them yo what's going on do
you thank you guys for tuning into the
stream good morning good afternoon good
evening how's everybody feeling yeah the
camera the cameras right there they can
see you now when you think about it the
real question is what don't you see on
Twitch and the more time you spend on it
the more you start to wonder how the
[ __ ] did we go from a guy strapping a
webcam on his head to this
[Applause]
like a lot of monumental technological
advances twitch started with a group of
dorky college kids and a crazy idea what
if someone were to livestream their
entire life that's what Justin Kahn
wondered when in 2007 he and his friends
launched an online reality show called
justin TV it's justin from justin TV
which is a website that broadcasts your
life live 24/7 from your point of view
that's right at a time when mainstream
reality TV was taking over the
entertainment industry and YouTube was
breaking down the boundaries to
broadcasting Justin so called life
casting service took off and then boom
all this press right a lot of hype
because this real life Truman Show type
thing right but unlike YouTube Justin TV
was raw and unedited you didn't need to
know how to cut or curate a video you
just turned on a webcam and before you
knew it you'd found a hassle free no
[ __ ] way to put yourself out there
what started as a way for Justin and his
friends to document their exploits as
freewheeling entrepreneurs quickly
transformed into a highly popular
streaming platform one that caught the
attention of both big-time media outlets
you know fewer inches in this piece or
more on web culture check out mtv news
blogs on the myspace page or my own
myspace page listed here below and some
pretty big names if the question was if
we had a chance movie record a song with
hanson so how did twitch spring from all
of this well as it turns out if you're
interested in seeing how a bunch of tech
savvy 20-somethings spend their time
you're going to see them do one thing
pretty consistently game what we decided
to do was go back to the drawing board
and basically sit in a room and try to
brainstorm ideas and with my co-founder
Emmett came with his idea and his idea
was let's focus on the gaming content on
our site just in TVs gaming
ten a gun so popular in fact that in
June 2011 the company launched its newly
branded gaming focused subsidiary twitch
TV from simple at-home streaming
sessions to full-blown tournament
coverage by 2013 twitch had cemented
itself as the one-stop shop for both
casual and competitive gaming eSports
kind of went from this thing that you
sort of did in your free time and you
showed your friends and said look look
how cool this could be and all of a
sudden it was on a screen broadcast of
thousands of people with you know
casters and analysts and everything that
you kind of always ever wanted from it
so it really helped sort of pick up
momentum for like eSports across the
board which allowed gamers with talent
and personality to build celebrity like
never before from variety streamers like
sodapoppin - pros like doublelift
two competitors turned educators like
day nine - which quickly became a haven
for entertainment and self-improvement I
have grown up playing Starcraft the
things that I have learned by playing
Starcraft have helped shape me so much
and I just want to do a big dedication
of the community to just say man just be
proud you are a Starcraft gamer there is
nothing more cool than being proud of
the things that you love it was also
bringing eSports into the homes of
countless gamers across the globe from
world's to the international - Evo - the
very first csgo major twitch played a
crucial role both in birthing modern
eSports and bringing them to the masses
here's the summoner's Cup let's give it
up for SK
still it came as something of a surprise
when in August 2014 this niche nor me
averse streaming service was acquired by
Amazon for nearly a billion dollars but
a very interesting acquisition for them
as you can see them trying to build up
their their streaming video business
there is possibly nothing hotter in
streaming video now it will include
Netflix on that nothing hotter than
twitch from that point on twitches
popularity skyrocketed it wasn't long
before twitch became the be-all and
end-all of live gaming content in the
West and from there something was born
something is vital and integral to
gaming as games themselves a legion of
lovable weirdos to share them with my
god but the real revolution was cultural
at some point twitch went from a simple
streaming platform to something in
between television and a social network
the place where competitors creators and
fans could come together and nerd out
but the games they loved YouTube even
had to release a standalone gaming
subsidy in 2015 in effort to match
twitches meteoric rise is YouTube gaming
going to kill twitch no it's not gonna
kill twitch but twitch does have a lot
to worry about in addition to truly
being the hub of eSports twitch proved
that watching other people play video
games wasn't just some dorky pastime it
was a full-blown mainstream
multi-million dollar industry and like
all industries
it had Titans from summit to lyric to
cutie pie to pre skin betting scandal
syndicate these were gamers who hadn't
just managed to make a living streaming
they've racked up a fortune Justin thank
you for the donation reap spawns I hate
you thank you for the donation did a big
wifey to in this day man haha man there
was no denying that streaming had become
a bonafide business and business was
booming with eSports on an unprecedented
rise and a new generation of streamers
coming up through the ranks people were
optimistic about the future of torch but
no amount of optimism pragmatism even
mysticism could have prepared the world
for what happened in 2018 the 2017 was
the year that which got as big as
everyone had prophesized 2018 was the
year it got bigger than anyone thought
possible
so what was it that made 2018 Twitch's
most explosive year to date well it's
pretty simple actually for tonight
now it started with battle Royales in
general but it wasn't until epics
cartoony spin-off that which managed to
reach new levels of insanity never in
the history of twitch had there been a
single title that dominated nearly the
entirety of the platform but the real
story was the cast of characters who'd
gotten there first who'd made a point of
capitalizing on fortnight's insane
success dog
Tim Lupo T foo shroud and of course
ninja so how long have you been playing
for tonight or been a fan I like Sam I
took ninja a former professional halo
player and early twitch adopter and
turned him into the most indescribable
successful streamer to ever live could
you be the first 10 million
dollar-a-year gamer definitely but you
must meet people who have no idea that
people make money is rare
he'd redefined what it meant to make
good money streaming he showed the world
that the sky was the limit
please welcome ninja
[Applause]
the issue was that in doing so he'd
helped twitch become the very thing it's
set out to oppose to go from edgy
underground and countercultural to well
entrenched in the mainstream a fortnight
fueled chaotic mess in which the old was
continuously being ousted by the new
there's gotta be a different [ __ ] way
for me for me in the twitch world that
go down this [ __ ] fortnight line man
it's the most boring [ __ ] on the [ __ ]
planet dude how do you guys like this
game so [ __ ] much by the time 2018
came to a close it actually felt as if
twitch had gotten too big for starters
it felt as if it was no longer the
organic everyman Enterprise it once was
are you a professional player if you
have a following on YouTube are you you
know are you are you just a top
competitive player like you are you top
of the leaderboards right if you
answered no any of those questions then
my next question to you is why would
anyone go out of their way to find
someone who has zero viewers and just
start watching them people don't like it
doesn't happen then there was the fact
that it had become standard practice for
viewers to be abusive [ __ ] towards
the very people they were supposed to be
supporting okay I'll tell you I'm just
depressed and it's [ __ ] up but it
probably makes me feel better I love
watching you I just want you to know
what I'm serious I want you to know that
I'm really affected so look look at me
okay
like
maybe he doesn't stop
lastly twitch had become virtually
impossible to moderate it turns out that
when you put a bunch of kids who've been
raised by reddit YouTube and soloqueue
on camera give them millions of dollars
and thousands of live viewers things are
bound to get out of control which is
sort of in its essence founded on young
people right like a lot of twitches
biggest stars they grew up almost like
parented by the Internet so well that
leads to good entertainment it can also
lead to some mix ups you know these guys
are literally right in front of us
sometimes just living their lives making
mistakes and I think we've seen a lot of
that over the last couple years some
tried to reform doesn't inject curse no
bleep that out of it no I didn't stand I
believe myself others decided to run
with it they removed the joy of sex on
twitch I'm gonna [ __ ] riot shut the
[ __ ] up you have any idea how [ __ ]
proud I am that the majority of my hour
streamed is under the joy of sex the
result was a massive controversy around
the subject of bans everyday streamers
were saying and doing crazy [ __ ] on
Twitch Milo and more often than not they
get flagged suspended or banned for it
don't get me wrong I deserve to be
banned
I should have been bad many times I'm
just kind of mad that it happened in
that stream and it was seven days that's
what I think I didn't have as harsh that
said a transgression was more likely to
be overlooked or ignored if it had been
committed by a tier 1 streamer someone
with the kind of clout that twitch never
thought they'd have to accommodate you
guys you guys [ __ ] killed all the
villagers man you suck my dick man y'all
[ __ ] get him you can suck with
my BP man I was trying to come today's
up-and-comers on the other hand were
more likely to invoke a trigger-happy
response to get punished over something
ostensibly in a fem
for those who remembered my cell phone
we had like um we had um goals and now I
can't really wear those on stream
because I feel like it would cause too
much controversy yourself and in some
cases over nothing at all there's gold
holy [ __ ] killed easily by 2019 it had
become clear that despite starting out
is the good guy as a kind of grassroots
antithesis to YouTube twitch had lived
long enough to see itself become the
villain and like all villains people
were looking to tear it down
[Music]
despite an unsuccessful launch in 2017
2019 saw the rise of Microsoft's
rebranded streaming platform mixer mixer
new the only way to destabilize twitch
was to come at it hard and fast they
also knew that they wouldn't be able to
unravel a decade old ecosystem overnight
and more importantly that they wouldn't
need to take the kingdom just the crown
so they did I know this may come as a
shock to many of you but as of today I
will be streaming exclusively on mixer I
know I know it's exciting and then they
snagged the king himself
it remains to be seen whether ninja and
shrouds departure will end up triggering
a kind of mass exodus what's clear is
that there's only going to be more
competition in the streaming space and
that twitch might not always be at the
center of it I'm joining YouTube
[Applause]
[Music]
ultimately there's no denying that
twitch isn't perfect it can sometimes be
a little too wild and unruly and in a
lot of ways its story is like that of a
teenage pop star they got too big too
fast and spiraled out of control the
funny thing is on some level twitch
actually did end up becoming exactly
what Justin and his roommates had
envisioned a place of rebellion
somewhere where you can be yourself be
successful and do it in a way that
doesn't need to make sense to anyone but
you and your viewers and while some of
that rebellion can feel oppressive and
overbearing a lot of it is just plain
old wholesome entertainment no I dragged
you down cuz you're like a pro and I'm
just like this new no no that wasn't it
at all we could have won that we got
really far together that was great and
I'm trashing they didn't even count no
no no dude come on man it's not like
that we don't mean you were just having
fun we could have won that you did a
great job that entire time oh I think I
promised you did and ultimately that's
the magic of twitch the fact that has
managed to turn a bunch of regular
people who probably would have gone on
to live normal lives into world-famous
educators and guys for my needs I used
viewmodel preset POS three so that's
classic view model you could change that
also just by going into your help
options game settings I use classic
Economist's the optic gaming situation
really surrounds one issue which is
mergers and acquisitions and above all
entertainers I just realized if we take
a mullet and glasses and slap it on you
and look at you through a fisheye lens
you're like fat doctor disrespect
it's made champions out of those who
choose to blow off conventional
responsibilities to chase the
expectations they had of themselves to
give their heart and soul to the silly
stupid beautiful thing that is gaming
it's basically impossible to overstate
the pivotal role that twitch has played
in bringing gaming to the fore it's made
kings and queens of people with the
courage to either compete at the highest
level or just welcome other unassuming
nerds into their lives and say hey let's
play hey what a friend oh you actually
miss yes
give us wrong he's actually men it
doesn't matter if you're a 12 year old
who just got home from school or an
accountant on their lunch break twitch
has made it so that anyone can open
their browser pop open a tab and spend
some time with someone they look up to
and for a lot of people that's a really
powerful thing
start broadcasting please click the
large red button in the upper right hand
corner if you have any questions you can
ask them at www.notimetoteach.com
you